ينضم الينا من باريس السفير باتريس باولي
المكلف بالتواصل باللغه العربيه في وزاره
الخارجيه الفرنسيه سيده باتريس الهدنه
التي اعلن عنها الجانب الامريكي شارفت على
النهايه ما حظوظ نجاح الجهود الدوليه
لتمديد هذه الهدنه وتحويلها الى وقف دائما
لاطلاق النار
شكرا مساء الخير
نحن رحبنا
لي يعني
عليها
برعايه الولاده المتحده ونامل ان تلتزم
الطرفين بهذه الهدنه وان تتحول هذه الهدنه
الى وقفه القنار مستدام لفتره طريق
للرجوع الى مائده المفاوضات ولحوار بين
الطرفين
لفتح
فتره انتقاليه مع حكومه انتقاليه تشمل كل
الاطراف سيد باتريس بين الامل والواقع هل
ترى بانه هنالك مؤشرات على ان تتحول هذه
الهدنه الى وقف دائما لاطلاق النار
هذا املنا هذا هذا فلنا منذ البدايه
طلبنا من الطرفين على الارض وقف اطلاق
النار هدنه هدنه انسانيه
لسببين الاول هو حمايه
المدنيين حمايه الشعب السوداني وكل
المدنيين السكان وان تعيشوا هذه الفرصه
ليعبر عن تضامننا مع الشعب السوداني الذي
يعاني عن الاحوال والهدف السبب الثاني هو
يعني كما قلت سابقا فتح الباب فتح الطريق
للرجوع الى مائده التفاوضات
ولاقامه وقف اطلاق النار مستدام
وفتره انتقاليه مع حكومه مدنيه تشمل كل
الاطراف
وتسمح بالخروج من من المازق الحالي
متع بها المجتمع الدولي لدفع الاطراف
للجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات وبتقديرك اي
من الوساطات العديد من الدول تقوم بتحركات
اي من المواصفات يمكن ان يكتب لها النجاح
اكثر من غيرها الاقليميه ام الدوليه
شكرا
لشغل لهذا السؤال مهم جدا افتكر انه اولا
نؤمن بكل جمع حاجه كل الجهود الممكنه
رحبنا بدور الولايات المتحده في فيما
يتعلق بالهدنه
وقفه النار لكن نحن منذ البدايه عملنا
بكل
الشركاء
بالاتحاد الافريقي مع الايجاد مع الولاده
الامم المتحده ومع الاعضاء الدائمه
العضويه في مجلس الامن اذا نؤمن بهاش كل
الجهود
وبما فهم كل الاطراف في المنطقه نحن على
اتصال مع السعوديه مع الامارات العربيه
المتحده مع مع مصر وهذا مهم جدا
هناك اجماع فيما يتعلق بالمطلوب المطلوب
هو مره اخرى هدنه
وقفت لك النار والرجوع الى مائده
المفاوضات وهذا هذه هي ايضا الرساله التي
نقلناها الى جنرالات
الحديث منذ الامس عن تشكيلي لجنه من اجل
مراقبه وقف اطلاق النار ومساعده الاطراف
للجلوس على طاوله المفاوضات هل ترى ان
هنالك تصورا واضحا لهذه اللجنه والاطراف
التي يمكن ان تتشكل منها او انه لا يزال
مجرد اقتراح لا اساس له
كل الجهود اللي قد تؤدي الى الى الى الى
وقفه لك النار مستدامه
ثابت مهمه جدا ليس لي اخبار خاصه فيما
يترك بهذه اللجنه لكن مره اخرى نحن نشجع
كل الجهود حول الاجماع الموجود بين
الاطراف يعني السعيد الدولي اعصاب
الاقليمي
لمعالجه الامور لان
الاحوال هل هي في السودان تثير القلق
لاثارها على الاستقرار في المنطقه وهذا
خطر كبير فنحن نشجع كل الجهود بما فيها
اذا
في لزوم لجنه سيد باتريس ان هنالك تركيز
على ضروره توقف اطلاق النار وايجاد هدنه
من اجل ادخال المساعدات الانسانيه ومعالجه
المرضى
نقل المصابين هل التركيز الدولي اليوم
ياتي على الهدنه الانسانيه بمفهومها
الانساني ان يتعدى
لاحل اسباب الخلاف او اسباب النزاع
والمواجهات
لا فائده وقفه النار
هي اولا انسانيه ثانيا سياسيه ونحن منذ
البدايه انذرنا عن خطر او تهديد الامن
الغذائي في البلد امن المدنيين فنحن مع
الهدنه منذ البدايه وقفت لك النار وقمنا
باجلاء المواطنين الفرنسيين للرعايه
الفرنسيه وايضا مواطنين من دول اخرى
وبما فيهم فيها دول عربيه المغرب ومصر
ودول افريقيه واوروبيه لكن نستمر في
جهودنا
ووجود حاليا
فرقه لوغن بين من بورسودان
ومن جده تسمع باجلاء بعض
الرعايه التي الذين خرجوا من البلد عن
طريق البر اذا هذا يعني وجود لاسباب
انسانيه لمساعدات
اللجنه لكن نحن نقوم ايضا
بتفكير فيما
تتمكن الجاليه الدوليه ان تعمله في
الميدان الانساني مهم جدا لكن الفائده
الثانيه لوقفه النار هي فائده السياسيه
السفير باتريس المكلف بالتواصل باللغه
العربيه في وزاره الخارجيه الفارس
الفرنسيه شكرا لك